Just look at that sunset.
...and the warm spring breeze in the air.
You can hear the birds chirping. I love this time of year!
You can just feel the love in the air.
WHERE?!
What are you doing?
Thanks for watching Microhorror: Love In The Air.
Go in the comments and tell me your dating horror stories and maybe it'll make a future Microhorror.
If you like this video, remember to like this video and subscribe because I am really excited for you guys
to see all the new content that's going to be coming to this channel very, very soon.
Until then, head over here and check out some of our recent Microhorror episodes and I'll see you in the next video.
Assuming we survive...
Assuming I get out of this freaking cell!